pour analyser le tout en juin Francis
cortellino il est économiste responsable
de l'analyse du marché de la région de
Montréal à la Société canadienne
d'hypothèque et de logements bonsoir
monsieur cortellino
bonsoir donc on parlait de Montréal
justement où on a franchi le cap
symbolique des 1000 dollars loyer moyen
de deux chambres en hausse de 5,4% c'est
la plus forte augmentation des 20
dernières années qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'on en est rendu là
plusieurs régions du Québec dans
Montréal donc ça a augmenté par un peu
pendant la pandémie mais si on enlève la
période pandémique mais le plus en plus
de migrants qui arrivaient au pays à
Montréal donc plus de logements à louer
de leur côté aussi vous en avez parlé de
l'accessoire devient plus difficile donc
les jeunes demeurent locataire plus
longtemps donc encore une fois ça vient
soutenir la demande de captive dans un
contexte ou même sont construit
énormément de logements locatif on a
construit pas assez cet en sorte qu'il y
a une rampe de logement locatif lorsque
au Canada et au secondaire on va pouvoir
voir un tableau monsieur cortolino où on
voit le coup des loyers dans différentes
régions
Savary énormément on a des hausses
partout on dit à peu près cinq ans et
demi pour cent Montréal 6 % Calgary 6%
Toronto mais Montréal Québec ça tourne
autour du 1000 dollars on passe à 1765
dollars à Toronto 2000 dollars du côté
de Vancouver qu'explique qu'est-ce qui
explique monsieur cortell que les loyers
soient encore beaucoup moins dispendieux
ici qu'il y aura au pays
est beaucoup plus grand que ceux de
Toronto
pour les dernières années
quand même de grande constitution
d'appartements locatifs
historiquement plus élevé et même les
loyers
par exemple dans la région de Montréal
les appartements locatifs présents en
1600$
pour les locataires qui viennent
d'emménager dans un logement on est plus
dans le 1250 dollars alors que ça
locataire est resté dans son appartement
on est plus dans le 975 dollars environ
encore une fois dépendant votre
situation le loyer auquel vous faites
face peut aller grandement oui c'est
d'ailleurs une des un des éléments
soulignés aujourd'hui par le
regroupement des associations de
locataires qui disaient on trouve que
les chiffres de la SCHL sont un peu
conservateurs quand vous regardez sur
Kijiji les loyers affichés sont souvent
50% plus élevés que les chiffres que
vous vous présentez votre rapport
aujourd'hui monsieur cortellino est-ce
que est-ce qu'en réalité l'explosion des
prix est pire que ce qu'on pourrait
penser
les deux choses mesure
des choses différentes dans nos loyers
pour Montréal vous avez tous les gens
que leur appartement c'est depuis 2 ans
50 ans donc ça écrit dans la moyenne
alors que lorsqu'on regardez les petites
annonces il y a des logements qui sont
vacants qui sont présentés et dans notre
enquête aussi on recense les loyers
moyens des logements qui sont
présentement vacants et dans le cas de
Montréal par exemple au environ à 1400
dollars on va encore une fois on
s'approche un peu des offres qui sont en
ligne mais dans notre cas le loyer moyen
inclut aussi des gens qui occupent leur
logement donc ça explique les
différences entre les différentes
données disponibles très bien bon les
loyers augmentent tout particulièrement
on le voyait avec Marie-claude lorsque
il y a de nouveaux locataires qui
arrivent dans un logement c'est quoi
l'effet du roulement de locataire sur la
hausse des prix
mais généralement qu'est-ce qu'on
observe c'est lorsque le logement
sébiber le propriétaire peut entamer des
rénovations qui peuvent avoir un impact
à la hausse les loyers aussi lorsque le
logement scléaire après quelques années
ou locataire était présent le
propriétaire peut regarder les
comparables du marché dans les environs
et ajouter son loyer à la hausse pour
être dans les comparables et c'est ce
qu'on aperçu avec nos nouvelles données
qu'on a publié aujourd'hui lorsque un
logement qui se libère les hausses de
loyer sont beaucoup plus élevées que
lorsque le locataire demeure dans son
appartement donc des loyers qui coûtent
beaucoup plus cher on a un taux
d'inoccupation qui pour l'ensemble du
Canada on dit en bas de 2% pour la
grande région de Montréal c'est 2% on
est en bas du taux qui est considéré ça
là monsieur cortellino
en effet c'est devenu de plus en plus
difficile dans la session actuelle pour
les locataires à Montréal ça permet à
nos pays de trouver un logement et on le
remarqué aussi dans un calcul de taux de
roulement des locataires donc la
proportion des locataires qui déménagent
et par exemple dans le cas de Montréal
avant la pandémie 2019 16% des ménages
locataires des ménages montréalais
déménagé 5% et en 2022 on a rendu à
seulement 10%. donc on peut voir que la
rareté des logements les hausses de
loyer qui sont plus fortes font en sorte
que les gens sont moins anciens
déménager étant un certain de pouvoir se
relâcher à un prix convenable et qui est
trouvé un logement de quoi on a besoin
pour pour résoudre en partie ce problème
là on parle souvent de construction or
elle s'était déjà accéléré comme vous
l'avez démontré dans le rapport
aujourd'hui dans les derniers mois les
dernières années est-ce que ça en prend
encore toujours plus
exactement donc on construit beaucoup
d'appartements locatifs et à ce sujet-là
le Québec et la région morale se
distingue de plusieurs autres régions au
pays où oui le locatif augmente mais le
condo est toujours dominant donc
Montréal au moins le locatif et le
produit dominant par contre comme on
vous l'avez inscrit faudrait doubler le
rythme de production des mises en
chantier au cours des prochaines années
pour venir marcher un peu plus abordable
donc oui et plus là mais c'est encore
nettement insuffisant il faut trouver
des solutions pour doubler la cadence
d'unités qui sont mis en marché afin de
restaurer la portabilité oui en
particulier pour les personnes faibles
revenus un monsieur cortellino qui sont
ceux pour qui c'est le plus difficile de
se trouver un logement on parle d'un
taux d'inoccupation pour les logements
abordables d'un pour cent à Montréal
combien il faudrait construire le
logement abordable pour répondre à cette
demande
donc encore une fois pour quand on parle
de doubler la production d'unité ou de
logements sur le marché faut visiter
tout le continent de logement donc faut
voir les logements sociaux parce que le
Déménage qui affecte le revenu auront
toujours de la difficulté à ce loger
dans le marché standard et aussi des
logements abordables donc en dessous du
prix du marché qui peuvent répondre à
des ménages sans être le revenu mais
quand même qui sont pas des revenus très
élevés et en vous voulez aussi si on met
des logements surpris du marché ça fait
en sorte que des gens peuvent libérer
d'autres logements aller dans ces
logements plus chers et ça libère des
logements moins chers donc un effet de
chaîne à travers la population qui
libère des logements mais encore une
fois ça revient à faire plus d'offres
dans tous les types de produits dans
toutes les gammes de prix pour répondre
aux différents besoins qui ont les
ménage Canadiens et les défis sont
grands merci beaucoup pour votre analyse
monsieur kurnin
merci à vous pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI